so at the top of the show when I was
laying out some of the principles that
we're talking about here I saw classical
liberalism falling into the conservative
category as you just said and it's funny
because while I consider myself a
classical liberal and ie can lay out
every liberal principle there is that I
would defend it's it's scary to me
because though because we get so caught
up in words that you know oh I don't
want to be considered a conservative
because I'm a liberal right it's a scary
proposition right well again it's it's
it's about limited government and
personal responsibility as far as I'm
concerned what you've told me is that
you are really somebody on my camp far
more so than somebody on Bernie Sanders
camp
well I'm liberal in that I'm for gay
marriage and I don't mind if you smoke
weed in your bedroom as a general rule I
do like lower taxes but I think we could
have a progressive tax at some level so
we probably disagree a little bit there
I do think you should if you keep making
more and more and especially as you
getting into the the dozens of millions
in the hundreds of millions yeah we
could have a progressive tax that would
tack the tax those people more I'm not
necessarily for the 90% tax that that
Bernie wants so I you know some of the
economic well I wonder let me ask you
why is it that nobody gave Dick Cheney
love because Cheney had a more
progressive position on on same-sex
marriage than Obama did when Obama was
still but a change all evolving Cheney
but Cheney didn't had until he was out
of office so that's you know it's a
little disingenuous what he did he saw
he still years before Obama said he was
in favor of gay marriage said I'm in
favor of allowing states to determine
this
he said that years before while he was
in office though I don't think that was
while he was all I know was years before
Obama cuz when Obama became president
2008 he's not only said that he was in
favor of traditional marriage he said
God was in the mix all of a sudden years
later God's no longer mix I'm not in the
mix four years ago then guard got out of
the mix but anyway the point is that
Dick Cheney said that he supported
same-sex marriage on a state-by-state
basis well before the left did well
before Obama did well before Hillary did
got no love
so isn't actually well that I think we
just go there because politicians are
pandering I mean that I don't know that
that makes Obama any more
liar than any other politician as much
as I'm told I'm here I'm talking about I
get you I'm talking about why somebody
didn't give it give Janie a couple of
attaboys on that I know that people on
the Left hate him call him a neocon and
believe he whispering in george w bush's
ear and guy bush to do all sorts of bad
things but I would have thought on this
issue since the left considered such an
important issue
I don't by the way um that they would
have not given Cheney a little bit of
weight you don't even sit what do you
mean you don't consider same-sex
marriage to be that big of a deal to me
it's give people equality and then let's
not to think about it anywhere that
would be what they're fair enough I'm
just saying I think the number one issue
in this country is self defense and in
the number one domestic policy issue as
I mentioned is the destruction of the
family these other things same-sex
marriage war on drugs global warming I
considered to be further down the list
yes so the war on drugs you're actually
for legalizing drugs right I'm for the
government getting out of it both
federally and at the state level yeah
and that would and interestingly uh this
may be a little boring for your for your
viewers though but in the in the earlier
in the 20th century we had the war
against alcohol the Constitution was
amended to fight the war against alcohol
and then it was a minute again when we
decided didn't work we've had since
Richard Nixon this war on drugs the
Constitution was never amended for that
and I don't understand why people don't
make the argument that it is illegal
what the federal government is doing
because in order to get rid of alcohol
Congress knew that they had to change
the Constitution which they did there's
no power article 1 section 8 that gives
the federal government the authority to
wage a war on alcohol or a war on on on
drugs but to do the one in alcohol they
change the Constitution and then reach
Ange it but they never did that for the
war on drugs yeah so how much of that do
you think goes to why the black family
has been affected I mean when you think
about the amount of black people black
men especially and minorities in general
that are in jail we now have for-profit
jails and a huge percentage of these
people are in jail because of drug
offenses well not that many about 12 to
15 percent but but but but whatever that
seems pretty significant whatever the
percentage is I think the war on drugs
should be rethought and we should deal
with it as a
problem and not a criminal justice
problem but the reason for the large
number of black behind bars it goes back
to what I said earlier about the
breakdown the black family and not being
taught the right kinds of values and
that has all sorts of other social
consequences including a greater
propensity to commit crime yeah
all right let's back up for a second
because you you quickly say something
about Hollywood and I know I follow you
on twitter and you rail against
Hollywood all I do basically your
argument that's like kicking a puppy
though
yeah it's becoming I can tell you no
it's not it's not that difficult right
so so just the other night you know you
were you were tweeting a little bit
about the Golden Globes and the targets
that your vase was taking last night I
show you you guys on CNN Don Lemon who I
had on last week was on the show last
week he was talking about Tavis Smiley
and you're not a fan of Tavis no I'm a
longtime he's a he doesn't preach what
he practices what he is as a
hard-working guy who came from Indiana
with the big poor family and has done
quite well with his life and instead of
telling people bust your butt do what I
did work hard stay focused it's demands
out to get you social justice races and
racism everywhere it's nonsense
Hollywood is an easy target because
these guys the Golden Globes they've got
these fine clothing designer clothing
and designer tux and and their jewelry
they're all anti Second Amendment but
they're all protected by armed security
guard and how many of them applied into
a Prius to get to and from the the the
ceremony I mean you're saying very few I
think very very few I think we're in big
a not a large number limos yeah a larger
and notice that notice there were
several Bill Cosby jokes I think three
or four Bill Cosby rape jokes not one
Bill Clinton rape joke pourquoi yeah
yeah do you think I mean I'm a firm
believer that a lot of them actually
privately are supporting Republicans or
at least they're voting Republican but
there's there's this idea that okay
we're gonna go on this can't you can't
sell out you can't say name one a list
young actor or actress who's an out of
the closet Republican just one young I
mean yeah I mean 2030s there you can do
it once you're Clint Eastwood once
you're Kelsey Grammer boy doesn't cut it
right no no but but somebody in his 20s
are Jennifer Lawrence Age star Nate one
there's got to be somebody right
they can't be 100% left-wing but they
will not say so because they know they
won't get parts right and you would say
that's not necessarily because they
believe those things as much as just the
structures in place
it's a bigotry in Hollywood that the
open-minded empathetic people they're
fine as long as you don't say something
that pisses them off yeah and and you
say that you're going to support Donald
Trump you won't work if you're 20 or 30
years old you won't work you're going to
lose jobs yeah so let's talk a little
bit about the times and think and think
about that these are these are the
people who are in charge of 80% of what
we see on TV and on in movies and if you
come out and you're 20 or 30 years old
and you're a rising star and you say you
know what listen to Larry oldest show
the other day I think I'm gonna vote
Republican finished done done now what
kind of power is that to influence the
minds of young people to shape this
country culturally it is massive there
was a book called primetime propaganda
by a young man named Ben Shapiro we're
getting about the show and and because
he looks so young and looks liberal
whatever that means he was able to get
on the record all these Hollywood
producers people they did Golden Girls
people that did cops and got them on the
record saying I would never hire a
conservative a conservative in this town
will be screwed a conservative in this
town cannot make it I intentionally put
left-wing messages in my fare I tried to
influence culture this way has them all
saying this and has him on tape and the
book came out and it didn't make any
difference
they didn't say I'm sorry I didn't say
we ought to rethink our assumptions he
interviewed Fred Silverman who at one
time is a head of ABC CBS NBC has Fred
Silverman on the record saying a
conservative cannot make it in this town
now if Hollywood has a great impact on
how we think on our culture and you have
this Gestapo essentially shutting out
people who are conservative what does
that say
it's scary too frightening to me
yeah well messaging messaging is
everything which actually brings this
back to what you said about try
before which I think is sort of
fascinating that he's polling better
with the black community is because he
has this sense of swagger which I think
you could probably relate directly back
to you know rap music and stuff like
that these guys aren't they're not
ashamed of their success and that so in
a weird way Trump is sort of doing the
exact same the exact thing that you want
to happen I agree but I think it's
another big reason that Trump is going
with white people one of the most under
polled things in this country is how
black people are pissed off about
illegal immigration when I was younger
there was a movie that came out of the
70s called car wash mm-hmm Richard Pryor
was in it yeah and George George Carlin
was in it and it was about a day in the
life of this car wash in south-central
not too far from where I grew up
virtually all the employees were black I
defy you to go to a car wash in South
Central now and see any any employee
who's black illegal immigrants and come
over and taken over this business and
black people see it and they and they
realize it and they are angry about it
and the Democratic Party however because
of what I said earlier about trying to
shift the electorate to the left has in
my opinion thrown blacks under the bus
on this issue and a lot of blacks who
are aware of it are not happy about it
and Donald Trump position on immigration
resonated with a lot of black people the
other thing about about Donald Trump
that I think in general not just black
people is appealing to me anyway and I'm
not quite sure why some of my fellow
Republicans are so adamantly opposed to
Donald Trump this guy Dave can self-fund
he doesn't need your money Donald Trump
was at a group called the Republican
Jewish coalition and he was asked a
question about does he feel that
Jerusalem should be the undivided
capital of Israel his answer is not
important he said something like I'm not
sure I haven't thought it through and he
got booed and Donald Trump looked up and
he said I don't need your money now
there's a guy named Nelson Sheldon
Adelson in Las Vegas he's a
multi-billionaire last election cycle he
gave Newt Gingrich ten Milton a lot of
estate a lot of people feel that but for
that Newt Gingrich is attack on Mitt
Romney and all the footage that he gave
Democrats to use in the general election
Romney might have won that's not the
point the point is he is a kingmaker
and right now he is trying to decide
whether he wants to give money to Ted
Cruz or to Marco Rubio he has lost Vegas
business interests I'm not mad at him
for doing something to pursue his
interests but the point is he expected
phone call to return to be returned
Donald Trump can say screw you to all
these people the people that get
subsidies for milk the people that get
suffer these for sugar the people they
get subsidies for this ridiculous
product known as ethanol the unions that
keep Amtrak running Donald Trump does
not need their money he does not have to
take their phone call so what guy can
really do what should be done for the
American people which is to get all the
crony capitalism and all these so-called
special interests out of our government
and get it down to the size that oughtta
be Boeing gets money from the government
Google gets money from the government
Dutch royal gets money from the
government this is corporate welfare and
the reason happens is because they give
contribution to the politicians who in
turn then do their bidding Donald Trump
does not need their money he is in a
position they downsize the government in
a way unlike any other politician I've
ever seen yeah so there's I mean there's
a lot of irony there it's you've what
you're really talking about is that's
truly systemic political tell me roblem
tell me about it the money politics so
that's and that saps that should unite
everybody across the board show that
stuff our sister should I mean right now
la is going to get to team two football
teams probably yeah Oakland and San
Diego and st. Louis are all vying to
come out here by the way all three of
them used to play here the rams used to
play here oak we have to play here and
the first la Chargers one of the AFL
teams started here and they move to
Sandy and now they I want to come back
why because their respective cities
won't give them hundreds of billions of
dollars in tax subsidies
why should a multi-billionaire get
millions of dollars from taxpayers who
then in turn have to pay all this to go
to the game and watch multi-millionaire
ballplayers it's right be yeah well
that's like sitting corporate welfare
that's a city's disgusting City field
where the Mets play in New York you know
that it was funded by partly by taxpayer
money I mean while the government's
bailing out citibank who has their name
a whole thing is reduced so the Trump
thing real quick one of the things is in
the first debate the first Republican
debate about three months ago now
I thought the unmasking that he did was
actually kind of a
amazing even though I disagree with him
on pretty much everything but you know
when they asked him about going to
Hillary's daughter's wedding right and
goes Elsie's wedding and he was like
yeah I give them money I get money the
wedding yeah I get money everybody I'm a
business guy I got it you know I got to
do what I got to do so in a weird way
even if you don't like so for my for my
liberal friends my friends I left even
if you hate the messaging and you know
all the Muslims stuff and all that even
if you hate all that the unmasking of
the system and that's why I've also
talked about how Bernie and Trump have a
lot in common because the core of what
they're doing is the biggest threat to
the system right Bernie and and Trump
have a lot in common in the sense that
the establishment is scared to death of
both of them but Bernie will make things
worse taking over large corporations
will make things worse raising taxes on
job creators will make things worse what
Donald Trump wants to do will make
things better hmm
all right well I barely got to any of
the questions I have here which is a
testament to you so I'm glad we got to
sit down so let me end this thing on a
little bit of the future where do you
think this country is going in the next
year do you so I sent are you supporting
Trump I haven't taken a position on
anybody yeah so I will support whoever
the nominee is over Hillary Clinton or
Bernie Sanders certainly yeah do you
view Hillary and Bernie both sort of as
equally yeah equally equally is it
really bad I mean I mean when you when
you've asked Hillary to give the
difference as Chris Matthews recently
did between a Democrat and a socialist
she couldn't do it debbie Wasserman
Schultz the chairwoman of the DNC was
asked the same question
she couldn't do it and Hillary has gone
further to the left because she's
threatened by Bernie Sanders she's now
come out by talking about a surcharge
tax on on on millionaires she didn't do
that before and she's also coming out on
the left now on guns she didn't to do
that before so Bernie's pushed her to
the left so as far as I'm concerned
their positions are pretty much
indistinguishable yeah and again this
may go to show why the system is just
broken because both sides in the primary
process have to stake out these
positions that they know that they're
not going to govern by right Richard
Nixon used to say when you want to win
presidency in the primary you run to the
right and then when you run in the
general election you run to the center
that's kind of how it works in the
primary season you have to run to your
base and then kind of run to the center
to front trying to get independents yes
how it works yeah all right well listen
I've thoroughly enjoyed talking to you I
didn't expect we were going to agree on
everything we didn't that's fine maybe I
learned a little something here maybe
you learned a little so have you learned
a little something come on so I see a
glimmer in your so did you move a little
bit towards the center well I consider
myself as a classical liberal I don't I
don't consider myself off the deep end
left and maybe I just I think in general
a lot of people on the Left are starting
to realize how do you feel about
vouchers uh I think we should have
vouchers I think you should have access
to god how do you feel about affirmative
action I do you feel about giving a
black person or brown person additional
points just because they're black and
brown over some equally qualified white
person you happy with that
unhappy don't care oh man now I'm being
interviewed alright so we I would say
that I think at some time at some point
in America there was a reason that it
really did make sense because they
because some of the more systemic stuff
still exists today and today it probably
doesn't make as much sense anymore
I think you would agree with me on that
because that's pretty much what you did
don't think it ever made any but that's
but that's exactly why I want to have
these conversations and why especially I
think that that liberals and
libertarians should realize that we're
sort of in the center together and that
there's a way to there's a way to work
together so that's exactly what I want
to do this err enough so all right so I
thank my guest
Larry elder you can check out clips of
the larry elder show and more Larry's
work at larry elder calm